seis años de prisión inconmutable si una
multa de 38 mil dólares deberá pagar el
destacado periodista guatemalteco José
Rubén Zamora como lo dictaminó en la
sentencia final el tribunal octavo de
ciudad de Guatemala a José Rubén Zamora
se le estaban acusando de tres delitos
chantaje tráfico de influencias y lavado
de dineros por los cuales la fiscalía de
este país estaba solicitando 40 años de
prisión en su contra los jueces hoy en
el tribunal resolvieron que no habían
pruebas creíbles para acusar los
sentenciarlo por los delitos de chantaje
y tráfico de influencias pero si lo
hallaron culpable en el caso de lavado
de dinero y determinaron que hay una
participación directa de José Rubén
Zamora de haber querido ingresar al
sistema financiero guatemalteco 300.000
quetzales cambiarlos por un cheque para
financiar su periódico 300.000 quetzales
estamos hablando de unos 38 mil dólares
y de esta manera Entonces los jueces
encontraron Que Zamora estaba atentando
contra la economía nacional de Guatemala
contra el sistema financiero
guatemalteco en todo caso seis años de
prisión es la pena mínima que se otorga
aquí en Guatemala por el caso de lavado
de dinero la pena máxima es de 20 años
pero desde ya hay organismos
internacionales que dicen que este es un
caso plagado de irregularidades Y
pedirán entonces una apelación